I have this beautiful daughter named jet
she's amazing she likes pizza
she likes ninjas and she like dresses
which makes me feel awesome because
she's a princess but she's also a ninja
that likes to chase zombies and I'm like
I'm doing a great job as the dead so I
instantly began to wonder what her
dreams would be and I thought to myself
how could I tell her that she could be
anything and everything in the world
that she wanted to be if I don't go out
and be everything that I ever want to be
in the world
I grew up one to beat Michael Jordan and
dr. Seuss Larry Bird's and Professor
Dumbledore Dr Sanders and Willy Wonka so
I started a little company called
imagination agency around the same time
I began to read books to my daughter
already hundreds and hundreds of
children's books the one guy realized
none of those characters looked like my
daughter so I thought if I don't make
black characters then who would and I
want to make a character that look like
my daughter
Jett so what better than a character
that was her that looked exactly like
her and it was named after her before
hey AJ was born
Haeju is my first children book that
released since then I've written books I
released my first animated short film
zoobi I got interactive children book
app some a games so look at me is like
your travel agent inside you want to go
to a great adventure but you come to me
at the imagination agency and we will
take you on that what did you want to be
when you grow up there could be anything
the world is your playground let's play
you
[Music]